what's up everybody to me Greg Miller
alongside the Prada Long Island Colin
Moriarty hello Greg go get that logo
empty not in a while Murphy gives you
the chills down your spine comic very
excited isn't that craft medium molecule
coming out masters of weird and so doubt
about it this triple a dream game what
the hell do you think this is about I
don't know I think that this is clearly
the game that they showed at the ps3 or
the ps4 work with or the dancing claim
man yeah he's everything this is just an
iteration of that game I think I mean I
think it's pretty obvious yeah they said
that they've been working on for four
years it was clear that tearaway was a
small team and that there was kind of a
stopgap game and it seems like bringing
at the ps4 is even another staff got for
the studio well they figure this out
this game is exactly what you would
expect for Media Molecule and they're
getting weirder and weirder and weirder
as time goes on that that on the bed one
case yeah but I mean what listen we
talked about a little bit when we did
our e3 wrap up games cast right over on
youtube.com slash kind of funny games is
the fact that it's yeah I think Media
Molecule when you look at this trailer
when you look at this game when you talk
to them about games like they are you
know at the forefront of games are art
and we are doing expressive amazing
things with it my question watching this
and even walk like this is still the
trailer right when we have to see a
little bit the demo when he was drawing
on the screen with the making these like
weird ass like basically ice cream like
you know it made me want soft serve ice
okay when he's a browser everything
makes you wanna saw serve ice cream when
you're seeing that it's just like I
don't know how to pitch that to somebody
that that's a game you need to buy and
grants and this is first blush this is
first trailer there's more to come but
like your puppeteering these things and
you're making dreams and we're sharing
dreams and i can see your dream and it's
like what the hell are you talking about
yeah i mean in in in reality I'm so
interested to sit down and talk to
chabon or one of the people Rex one of
the people from Media Molecule that we
know and just be like so what the hell
is it because this is a game that you're
going to need to sit down and figure out
how to tell people I have no doubt that
the core of this game is gonna be great
yeah and it's gonna be something
interesting and different because that's
what Media Molecule doesn't so they with
a little big planet that's what they did
with tear away but how are they going to
express what this is right that's a huge
problem I had no idea we really what the
hell they were talking about I was just
excited to see the medium
keylogger for the first time ever you
know so I had really is old they said
they're gonna Paris game show we'll see
you know you know that or games week and
that's later this year they have to
figure out a message for this very very
very soon right this should be this has
Morpheus written all over it too in my
opinion even though they didn't say that
that was only predictions but about
creating dreams and interconnect and
dreams being interconnected and I
understand what they're saying in
essence they're were they're basically
saying your dreams are weird yeah and
there are no rules yeah and that sounds
great but it's very abstract if you're
not there this is a game that seems to
have been made in a silo in a way you
know because of course uh they need to
be able to message us other people yeah
I mean that's the alarming thing of like
the like it's just even this thing of
like is the you see the polar bear we
come back and the polar bears head is on
the guy who's playing piano it's just
like what the hell's I like that I like
this part that was my favorite part with
it when the one the little bear pump
whatever you would call it yap hafsa
starts licking them that's how many
important aight so cute you can be a
part of that if you wanted I could be
but I just and I stay in your room and
then I could come in and suck the Sun
like that I don't even know do you think
this something you brought up that was
interesting I mean like as Media
Molecule continues get weirder and
weirder do you think Sony ever has to
step in and rein them in like you talked
about a right big little big planet or
the original was a success because it
was a platformer people could wrap their
head around had a cute little guy and
then they that success kind of kept
running and running and running to
making crazier crazier things till our
here yeah I'd uh it's clearly so he's
not ringing them yeah so but if this
doesn't sell do they rein them in if
this doesn't sell I'd be really afraid
for me to molecule because you know it
mean that's just the reality of the
business today and the way Sony treats
their studios now there's no room for
for a big flop so whatever i'm not
saying that this is necessarily a big
flop but this has this has commercial
failure and on and if they don't if they
don't you know communicated effectively
that's my major concern with this game
communicated effectively Media Molecule
has all the talent the world everyone
knows that you know so figure it out and
message the game and so like there's a
little else to say because don't even
know what the hell it is yeah yeah final
question for you Colin yeah if it is a
Morpheus title when do they reveal it at
some more fu style probably Paris I'm
sure we're gonna learn a lot more about
the game of Paris I'm sure that with
Quantic Dream's game is going to be
probably the marquee
that for Sony would assume David cage
man ladies and gentlemen this is dreams
and they're weird let us know what you
think and get ready for all sorts of
cool coverage from us at gamespot com /
III